المشاهدين وفي ظل التطورات الماساويه التي
تجدها العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم في هذه
اللقطات محاولات لجلاء بعض المرضى من
المستشفيات السودانيه في ظل استمرار
الاشتباكات وتحت القصف وتحت
الرصاص في محاوله لاجلاء عدد من المرضى
المحاصرين في احد المستشفيات في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم اذا هذا هو ما يعيشه
السودان الان حتى المرضى في المستشفيات لا
يستطيعون مغادرتها وانما هناك محاولات
لاجلاء المنومين ونقلهم الى اماكن امنه
لوصول تلك الاشتباكات حتى الى المستشفيات
في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم اذا محاولات
لاجلاء بعض المرضى والمصابين من داخل
المستشفيات في السودان تحت الرصاص وتحت
القبائل كما نشاهد في هذه اللقطات فلنتابع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات